vous allez avoir en façade un écran de
4,6 pouces un peu standard sur lequel
vous allez pouvoir regarder toutes vos
infos sur le smartphone comme vous le
feriez façon un peu classique lorsque
vous l'ouvrez ça va vous dévoiler un
écran de 7,3 pousse les deux sont des
écrans amoled s'arrête vraiment
intéressant parce que
[Musique]
oh
dès que l'âge horaires de ouf c'est
compliqué six ans déjà la joie dans la
tronche ça fatigue ya du bruit 1 ce
matin à new york
on voit pas le haut de gamme player
style politique pas à leur faire très
beau ça c'est un peu comme un jeu une
nouvelle journée qui commence se cogner
en arrivant ça c'est fait douch fait
gèle pas mis dans wurz est propre
allen allen hockey croyez moi sur parole
donc là le deuxième jour à new york
aujourd'hui c'est une journée qui assez
dingue j'ai un pote à moi qui transitent
par jfk est aujourd'hui qu'ils
reprennent demain
donc on va sur la journée ensemble
lorsqu on va bien se marrer je vais vous
présenter dans quelques instants le
temps qu'il arrive d'ici 2-3 heures à
peu près ça mais sait-on de manger un
bout à la laissez moi vous présenter
l'un des mystères aujourd'hui mika élu
par les français comme un certain mika
ben ouais salle alors 20 contre mikhail
en transit ils devaient arriver que hier
à new york il fera très vite répondu
coup pour qu'on fasse le jeu d'ensemble
et la soirée va du coup c'était pareil
je vais finir un peu plus tant c'est une
bonne idée et chanter la langue ça va
très très mal à traiter géant tout ça
bon coup et c'est parti on va continuer
à parler de teck aujourd'hui mais avant
et je vais vous faire faire un petit
tour ma chambre
j'aime bien me faire visiter un petit
peu les endroits que je visite je vous
ai déjà montré hier la jeune vampire
state building mais franchement la météo
est bonne par contre j'ai ça en face et
ça et je sais pas du tout ce que c'est
des trucs un petit peu atypique alors
vous avez toujours les les petites
sicard now ça c'est vraiment typique de
new york mais au dessus de ce bâtiment
que c'est pas qu'elle ait ce bâtiment
messancy marrant de voir son milieu des
grands buildings
c'est assez cool bon maintenant et ce
mot faire plus tu tournes la chambre
jusqu'à l'hôtel pennsylvania qui juste
en face du madison square garden hyper
bien placé je suis à dix minutes à pied
même pas de times square en placement il
fou furieux
c'est cool l'hôtel est pas officines par
contre l'emplacement est énorme et le
prix est plutôt que dans un petit lit
kosir peu bois très sympathique bon un
téléphone pour appeler la réception de
hauts fonds très importants de
s'hydrater
blaquart à la avec tout le nécessaire
une télé un cadre moins en face mon ordi
ou chantera envoyé ma première vidéo sur
la chaîne us donc normalement dans 20
minutes c'est ok donc c'est un peu le
stress toute première fois pour moi là
dessus et on arrive ici dans la salle de
bain alors une salle de bain avec une
louche c'est bon un petit peu old school
mais ça roule petit toilettes c'est cosy
c'est mignon c'est tout petit voilà bon
maintenant parce que je vous propose il
est 9h30 du matin de 10 heures géographe
un talisman jeunes beaux et puis juste
après c'est mon hôtel
jusque là haut il ya quoi comme quelque
chose comme dix huit étapes
[Musique]
madison square garden
vraiment un temps aurait aujourd'hui il
pleut c'est pas terrible c'est très très
très très humide mais bon il fait pas
froid l'année dernière quand je suis
venu à cette même période
il faisait moins 15 va ça va déjà mieux
[Musique]
bon aujourd'hui on se retrouve ici à new
york pour parler du samsung galaxy être
alors samsung galaxy f pour fold
flexfold hebel smartphone filiales ont
leur samsung galaxy mix on sait pas trop
là qu'on est devant mon hôtel
il fait quelque chose comme je sais pas
ça il suffit de grès ya beaucoup de vent
et il fait froid il pleut plus c'est
déjà ça mais c'est pas grave au point on
doute de rien dans les cahiers parce
qu'on aime 60 m en extérieur peut être
dans la chambre d'hôtel pour vous parler
ça alors ce qui est très intéressant ce
qu'il faut comprendre là dessus c'est
que ça va être vraiment une nouvelle
façon de naviguer avec son smartphone je
prends ma carte de tatouage expliqué
vous allez avoir en façade un écran de
4,6 pouces un peu standard sur lequel
vous allez pouvoir regarder toutes vos
infos sur vos smartphones comme vous le
feriez façon un peu classique mais
lorsque vous l'ouvrez ça va vous
dévoiler un écran de 7 3 pouces les deux
sont des écrans amoled
ça va être vraiment intéressant parce
que ça va ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives
quant à la navigation sur internet à
savoir que lorsque vous allez avoir des
notifications assénait tout ce que vous
voulez regarder votre agenda pour
regarder comme ça c'est rapide c'est
simple c'est compact ça marche très bien
alors ce que vous nous ferez vous avez
une nouvelle façon de naviguer nouvelle
façon de regarder vos vidéos de lire des
bouquins d'aller sur internet de faire
tout ce que vous voulez même de jouer à
des jeux vidéo un peu comme vous le
feriez sur une tablette
sauf que toute cette tablette vous allez
avoir dans un format hyper compact qui
ressemblera franchement un smartphone
classique comme on l'a aujourd'hui il
sera juste plus épais en terme de points
il doit faire sensiblement la même chose
que ce qu'on trouve actuellement à peu
près 200 g
en gros il ressemblera dans trait pour
trait un smartphone classique sauf que
en réalité et un sourire comme si vous
frontier est la langue des âniers aux
ouvriers la caverne d'ali baba z avoir
des crampes ce travail en plus grands
sacs ou ça sera vachement plus
intéressant
jour d'entrée vidéo de ses ébats
amoureux de toi même au contraire je ne
puisse plus tout supporter je m'en
faisais plutôt le deuxième cas en fait
c'est parce qu'elle force de boire
[Musique]
via des dameuses tisot fait notable de
performance on devrait avoir pour le
marché nord-américain un snapdragon 855
nouveau soc de qualcomm et pour le reste
du monde on va voir un évier 9820
probablement deux versions 6 giga de ram
8 gigas de ram et puis côté stockage san
mateo gil à du stockage de 256 go de
stockage
en tout cas ça devrait être une bête qui
pourrait franchement ma tournée et ce
point de vue landré pas se plaindre en
plus de ça on ira les mauves tous ces
écrans on aura une énorme batterie de
6000 milliampères heures en fait il sera
divisé en deux batteries avec une
recharge rapide on imagina passe quelque
chose qui va forcément consommer donc il
faut forcément derrière un smartphone
puissant performant avec une vraie belle
autonomie pas se retrouver en rade d'ici
très peu de temps
en plus de ça ce qu'on voit ce qui est
super intéressant avec effectivement
c'est une nouveaux écrans ce camp au
pouvoir par exemple faire du multitâche
on peut faire déjà aujourd'hui mais bon
sur en kit et prendront même si vous
avez un écran de 6 pouces de 6,5 ou son
équivalent du le petit chat c'est jamais
bien génial là vous allez pouvoir le
faire sur un écran de 7,2 blues les pour
faire du multitâche avec deux
applications pourquoi pas trois
applications en même temps et ça pousse
ça peut être aussi super intéressant à
la rabaissant la voilà la thèse boire un
p'tit coup open 6 bars et non pas le
fait des relais sont là les verts
elles sont bonnes a bel et bien c
r locale côté photo vidéo on devrait
avoir un triple module photo à l'arrière
samsung a passé le k du triplet mode ou
photos cette fois ci a priori un des mes
19 ans on devrait le retrouver un peu
partout on devait avoir une caméra 12
mégapixels ouverture variable comme
nation galaxy s le s9 plus et galaxy
note 9 une caméra qui ouvre à f 2.4
jusqu'à f un point cinq ans de recevoir
un tel objectif 12 mégapixels et on
devrait avoir aussi un très grand angle
pourrait chercher à filmer un peu plus
grands et faire des photos très grand
tante
à l'avant on peut avoir une caméra celle
filles de 8 mégapixels au niveau de
l'ouest il doit tourner sur le nouvel os
qui s'appelle one i want your way alors
c'est un smartphone qui pourrait être
présenté dans le cadre du mwc dernière
samsung avait déjà lancé le galaxy les
galaxy s 9 h 9 plus juste à l'ouverture
du mwc la veille au soir là on pourrait
avoir sensiblement la même chose
on imagine une conférence avec le
lancement du nouveau flagship et
pourquoi pas du samsung galaxy ace ça
doit être super cool en tout cas je vous
invite à vous abonner parce que je serai
présent ou en w c'est une fois de plus
cette année donc du coup dès que le
smartphone sera disposé à présenter la
prendre en main les rencontres et les
tester un peu voir un peu tous les côtés
puis vous montrer tout de suite la
couleur semble qu'on peut en faire quoi
ça peut être franchement cool donc d'y
abonnez vous moi je suis impressionné
ici par le nom d'écran que tu as dans un
bar pour regarder les matches
c'est complètement hallucinant où que tu
sois tu peux regarder et bien évidemment
siroter un cocktail tu es d'accord aux
courses alors mettant la question c'est
pourquoi aller sur des smartphones à
écran pliable dit on a déjà notre
smartphone pourquoi est-ce que vous
devriez aller sur un fond d'écran biel
est ce que ça réellement un sens c'est
ce que ça a un intérêt
est ce que ça vaut le coup de mettre
autant d'argent pour passer d'un
smartphone classique un smartphone à
écran pliable alors pour moi c'est un
sens parce que c'est pas vous n'avez
plus loin en termes de multimédia en
termes de contenu on voit que ça va être
la nouvelle référence d'ici 2020 toutes
les autres marques devraient s'y met y
avoir effectivement aux pochons mini
vivo
lg rapidement ou huawei au cigare aux
eagles a sorti sa copie ya pas très
longtemps les smartphones à écran
pliable vont venir les références tout
simplement parce qu'on a besoin toujours
deux plus grands écrans pour profiter
des expériences multimédias toujours
plus intéressant que jean plus
performante et là pour le coup ça va
être difficile d'y couper en tout cas
d'ici quelques années en 2019 on peut
complètement faire l'impasse
mais d'ici 2020 2021 2022
ça va être à mon avis impossible de ne
pas aller sur ce type au logis
smartphone parce que ça va tenir la
référence alors aujourd'hui c'est un
smartphone qui avait coûté un peu cher
on va le retrouver à 1600 euros à peu
près on va pas mettre ce prix là mais
dites vous bien que dans les années à
venir les primes ont forcément des c'est
donc une fois que sera démocratisée
forcément ça peut être un peu moins cher
à sa marque samsung devrait sortir un
million de produits pour venir tester le
marché et si ça marche en sortir
d'autres par la suite trois en tout cas
intéressant à vous de me dire en
commentaire si vous seriez prêt à
franchir le pas et achetée un samsung
galaxy s samsung galaxy x connaît pas
encore le nom est ce qu'un smartphone à
écran pliable pour vous c'est un intérêt
et est-ce que vous verriez avec un très
grand écran comme ça est ce que quand
multimédia ça vous intéresse c est ce qu
au final vous seriez prêt à mettre votre
tablette au placard en avoir qu'un seul
et même produit un smartphone à écran
pliable et est ce que pour vous ça va
venir complètement remplacé la tablette
à la maison et au final ne faire qu'un
seul et même produit parce que je sais
pas vous mais moi tout un camp
apple avait présenté son ipad je me suis
dit mais c'est quoi ce truc au final
c'est s'est jamais plus qu'un iphone
avec un grand écran alors après on l'a
trop des usages être une place dans nos
foyers mais au final avec un smartphone
à écran pliable ça va venir
effacer cette gamme de produits à moins
d'aller encore sur des tables est
beaucoup plus grande en train pour usage
personnel monsieur madame tout le monde
c'est bien mon avis effacer cette
typologie de produits et pour qu'on se
retrouvera avec des smartphones à écran
pliable
ça peut être intéressant dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire dites
moi si vous seriez prêt à l'acheter que
je vous invite à vous abonner parce que
forcément on va parler beaucoup de
smartphones à écran pliable on a su bien
que tu as fontonne là je continue je
pars d'ici deux jours
las vegas que tu es mon trip un peu new
yorkais ya plein de choses à vous
montrer ici pour profiter en même temps
d'accoucher visiter mais un petit peu
dans l'atmosphère donc voilà on continue
dans cette jolie journée
[Applaudissements]
avantageux
mais bon il n'obtient pas le concept
cohérent en plein c'était un message
négatif
quitte à délaisser un dollar n'était pas
airbus
on peut être un dollar sur 10 soit 24
dollars ça veut dire que la merde alors
qu'a été très bons on avait demandé
conseils sur le macadam
je croyais et le conseiller son mac est
restée dans les espaces avec sa crosse
alors que moi je leur ai donné carrément
20 20 à 25% l'autre soir et dire que je
suis à vernier ge aurait pu laisser 2% à
presque isle et quelque chose comme 1
22h07 ici à new york autant dire qu'avec
le décalage horaire il faudrait quelque
chose comme 4 heures du matin en france
donc il est l'heure d'aller dormir pour
repartir demain sur bonnes bases et
demain on va aussi parler nos sujets
super intéressant je ne vous en dit pas
plus pour l'instant
on se retrouve demain d'ici là soyez
sages portez vous bien et bonne nuit cas
où